anybody is Gary Vaynerchuk at CEO of
vaynermedia in this post I just actually
want to tell you a story and it over
pretty much explains a situation that
I'm seeing in my mind right now and in
the market that baffles me which is the
lack of humility and the lack of
long-term thinking and a lack of
patience in our marketplace today I
believe take one step back for two steps
forward is a tremendous business model
and garnishes tremendous results however
many people tend not to do it and
actually don't want to do it legally a
story about after I built my wine
business why my recon from a three to 40
billion dollar business started this
wine channel and things started
happening and I wanted to get into the
tech sector so I went to a jacuz Leo
Laporte meet up in two thousand seven or
eight and I basically was the help here
I was at this forty to seventy person
meetup in the tech scene in San
Francisco and I was behind the table
like this with a bunch of bottles of
wine and some wristbands and some
t-shirts promoting my show I was 41 four
people for three and a half hours my
fact I have some clips on the swatches
as you can see there really see me up
there in the beginning kind of about
that he saw me but it was this chaotic
little party nobody cared there was no
press you know the report was kind of
like the taste maker in the room I never
met him never said him look to him all I
did was I realized one key thing if
you're entering into a new business if
you're entering into a new industry or
if you're even entering into a new space
you're living take your business and
make it more tech oriented you don't go
men and pound your chest and say look
what I've done in construction business
you tech nerds new tech people your tech
writers take me serious now they sell
concrete on the internet no you have to
figure it out and basically make
yourself part of the community and
realize and swallow your pride and bring
some humility to the situation and
realize that you need to become part of
this I need to immigrate into the
culture and that that's something we
need to start over which is what I did
and what has been very surprising to me
is I'm meeting so many entrepreneurs big
businesses small businesses that are now
trying to get into the tech space bv6
pivot into other industries and they
think what they did before actually
matters it doesn't it creates some sort
of context that you're now playing in a
new field do you think that all the
baseball executives gave a crap that
might be Jordan was the greatest
basketball player of all time or some
people believe I know but you know was
the greatest basketball player of all
time when he started his baseball career
they did it wasn't a fad for for the
White Sox and so I think we need to
think about that a lot of ego and just
Oh too much lack of awareness of what it
takes to be successful in today's world
one step backwards two steps forward